前期都能这样，
你以为他能给你多少？
不好意思，
八五年的，
现在是分手，
未婚家就是说因为孩子的问题嘛，
因为孩子有三个，
然后说要分孩子啊，
或者是分开孩子啊，
然后总是在心里上面没有办法去让孩子承担这些问题，
所以说每天就是说这个回教，
然后一直都心情很不好，
由于我本身有的能力也比较差吧，
然后也各种嗯，
社交啊，
也是弄得不是很好，
然后现在就是这个孩子不知道怎么办，
当初你俩分开是你想分开还是他想分开，
一个是我想分的，
你想分的主要原因是什么？
因为确实很多年，
然后一直也没有感情，
他的性格也是很不好，
就一直都不是很理想嘛，
然后最后就分了，
分了之后就吵，
孩子共同抚养，
然后我也不理解，
也不告诉任何亲戚朋，
有就是说没有第三个人知道，
那当时你俩分开的时候，
家里面的主要财产给了谁？
财产这方面的话，
其实我们上台可。
对吧，
因为我给了他100个，
一套房子一个车，
就回到他名下，
基本上是没有这个经济，
结婚了，
但是现在的问题就是，
呃，
面对这三个孩子，
然后我就一直很迷茫，
就是你俩主要家里靠谁挣钱呢？
主要是我经济这方面是没什么问题，
我主要就是心理上的问题，
就怕孩子以后也变得呃单亲家庭会变不好之类的，
虽然说是心理压力就很大，
这孩子的嗯，
多大了？
分别是男孩女孩是一个什么情况呢？
两个女的，
一个男的，
那女的已经是初中了，
养个小的就三四年级吧，
这孩子都是他妈妈一手带大的吗？
就是孩子的奶奶什么的帮忙吗？
呃，
没有，
基本三四三四几代的，
然后就是每天晚上回家就是看一眼小孩一天子哭一个，
所以说不知道是该分还是不该分的，
三个孩子当中有没有那种高敏感高需求的宝宝，
就是心理上啊，
就非常脆弱的那种宝宝，
所以说怎说一般吧，
对初中的那个大的也是女的，
就是说心里有点叛逆，
老是说话说不听，
等怕他以后就是变成单庭家庭的，
就不好管住了。
你实话实说，
在你的心里，
如果这3个孩子让你选一个的话，
你要带谁走，
其实我都行，
因为我确实孩子我还是看的比较重要，
之前有跟他谈过这个问题，
就是要怎么分，
结果呢，
分气证明要怎么分，
什么分就不吵架的时候，
反正就又沉默了，
你们当时去办那个证的时候，
协议上怎么写的，
共同抚养，
然后养生，
基本上钱不是我不是了，
因为他就不是带的钱，
不是我在抚养兄弟，
你这话说的真的是不招人待见哦，
啊，
你要想他一个人带3个孩子，
哎，
你还指望他去挣钱吗？
啊，
那肯定是你养啊，
是不是，
咱是是说这个不指望他他怎么样吧，
主要就是说现在的这个心理压力，
然后一直放不下，
也不知道怎么弄，
然后就是一直心情不好，
反正回到家看到他，
我都一年都不看他一眼，
兄弟，
你这话说的，
你要是对一个女人没感情，
你让人家夸夸夸给你生三个孩子，
你有没有想过，
你这种做法也是害了她一辈子，
你对她没感情，
你对她没感情的话，
你早说呀，
你趁着她二十几岁的时候，
你就说呀，
让人家可以自由的去外面去选择呀，
你对一个女人没感情，
你让人EE夸生三个孩子，
现在人到中年了，
40多岁了。
就是都是于意外吧，
以前相对来讲就是种比较无知吧，
我跟你讲啊，
你这个事情啊，
日子还得接着过，
你别讲什么意外不意外的，
孩子已经出生了，
就像你说的，
孩子是无辜的，
得负责呀，
你还得接着过啊，
就是因为3个孩子现在就算分手了也分不开啊，
啊3个孩子人家对吧，
感情好啊，
姊妹啊，
你这分哪个也分不开，
你这日子还得接着过啊，
我自己又不能不回去啊，
然后我回去了又心情不好，
我跟你讲啊，
在心理学上有一个说法，
就是谁痛苦谁改变，
你别老是从你的这个角度来看，
觉得你挺亏的啊你第一你找了一个你不怎么爱的女人，
不怎么喜欢的女人，
第二你一个人养家，
你老觉得你挺亏，
你挺辛苦的，
那有的时候我们客观一点啊，
那女的这一辈子是不是也挺亏的？
第一，
找了个男人，
男人对自己没感情是吧？
第二，
E夸夸生了三个孩子，
这一辈子就被绑死在这个家里面了，
没有别的可选择了，
说句难听点的话，
你让他改嫁他都不好，
改嫁了没有人要他了，
都一样的，
从他那个角度来说的话，
他这一辈子也挺亏，
也挺不值的。
好两个都觉得不值得的人怎么才能找？
一个契合点就是这三个孩子挺健康哦，
这三个孩子对吧，
不缺胳膊不不少腿的，
然后也没有抑郁症，
也没有那个什么自闭症的，
也没有什么，
嗯，
大问题，
都挺健健康康的啊，
只能从这个方向找幸福感了。
我说句难听一点的话，
大哥你一年挣多少钱？
收入的话，
如果按照普通跟来讲的话，
基本上是实现财务是有，
未必哦，
你总共给你前期也就一套房100万，
一辆车，
那还离财务自由还远的很多，
但这是我安排的，
不是他安排的，
也就是说你跟他离的时候你还藏心眼儿了，
你自己可能藏了个四五百万是不是啊？
怎么双贷，
我不止跟你前妻离婚的时候，
你只给你前妻给了个零头，
你自己可能有个上千万，
你给了他个100万是吗？
呃，
因为财务这方面他从来不管，
也不知道我有多少，
然后我他就他就听我的了，
所以说财务这方面都不是问题，
但是我对他也不吝啬啊，
我现在他有什么都是给要我直播间的其他女人啊，
警惕杀猪盘啊，
不要觉得他说他有千万，
你们就往上扑，
我告诉你们啊，
所以说现在就是还是继续过呗，
就是每天我们回家我都说明了吧，
我我明跟你说吧，
这位大哥，
你也很难找到所谓的什么真爱，
没有人真正爱你，
你就算找个年轻的漂亮的，
也就是图你兜里那几个。
图，
你那几个钱没有人真正爱你，
你知道原因是什么吗？
嗯，
因为你没有真正爱过任何人，
可能也是你对你老婆也没有真正的爱，
你对几个孩子可能有怜惜，
可能有作为父亲的一个责任，
但是你对几个孩子也没有真正的爱。
你要是对几个孩子有真正的爱，
你会在离婚的时候只给你前妻分那么点财产吗？
不会的。
那么点的基础啊，
但是后面我还是会有很多安排啊，
孩子也给他安排一套房啊，
然后那孩子的这个过程都得靠我来养的，
这个我是自己知道的呀，
嗯，
这3个孩子如果想养的好的话，
也是挺钱的是吧，
万一将来他们又想要留学，
又想要学什么这那的也挺费钱的，
你这点钱的话，
你要说财务自由的话，
那我觉得还不够格，
一般做人都低调一点啊，
还得往下过，
反正我就明确告诉你了啊，
就是像你这样的情况，
你再找个女的的话，
就算你贪恋人家的年轻，
贪恋人家的美貌，
人家也不可能真正爱你的，
主要现在是有钱也不开心，
然后我不知道是不是心里有问题了，
如果你要老觉得自己心里很压抑啊，
心里面很不开心啊，
嗯，
还是要寻求一下专业的帮助，
去医院去看看，
再吃点药，
咱吃点药，
因为你的这个情况，
如果你这一辈子在男女关系上，
在爱情上，
你没有真正享受过那种快乐幸福什么的话的话，
可能会是一个遗憾。
但是对于你的妻子来说的话，
我觉得他这一辈子更是挺遗憾的，
你们现在需要的就是在孩子身上去找一点幸福感了，
嗯，
再见，
这真的是啊，
挺典型的啊，
我只是说客观的讲，
她就是很典型的一个状态，
就是对老婆爱答不理，
对老婆也没有什么真正的这个爱，
但是夸夸夸生几个孩子，
这经济上呢，
老婆也不掌握他的经济大权，
也不了解他挣多少钱，
哎呦，
我就这直播间这这些女人们啊，
你们真的这这老公挣多少钱这个事儿你们留点心眼儿吧，
上点心吧，
好不好？
嗯，
在我直播间，
首先第一点龙费律师我自己可以做到，
我不会跟任何一个连麦的人去造假，
去做剧本，
去吸引眼球，
我这辈子没干过这样的事儿，
从我连麦的第一个人到今天的这一个人的话，
我从来没有干过这样的事儿，
去搞剧本，
搞炒作，
骗你们啊，
骗你们的眼泪或骗你们的同情，
骗你们的流量，
我没干过这样的事儿，
但是我不排除可能存在那种连麦的人，
他来的时候，
目的可能你不是说找个律师来聊天，
目的是让周围这1万多人听听他为他多有实力或者怎么怎么样，
所以你们自己一定要呃，
谨慎的去辨别吧。
他说句实话，
就算他真的这么有实力的话，
你也不要去扑，
这样的男人啊，
没有真爱，
而且他对前妻前妻都能这样，
你以为他能给你多少？